[Music]
and hang on news submitted by Fuego
waffles oh my god wake up
imagine how awful that might be good I
think you go turn any iteration of a hot
cheeto into something good no I've tried
the hot cheeto chicken fries things from
Burger King no was it it was a scam it
doesn't taste anything like Hot Cheetos
holiday just [ __ ] up but yeah that's
like a hot cheeto
that sounds wasn't think it was yeah but
it would taste good if it was a mom a
man clings to the hood of an SUV and a
high-speed road rage incident oh [ __ ]
it's not worth it you are so crazy on
the road I understand that there's a
study that did it they said people rage
on the road because they don't connect a
human with the car they just see a car
instead of seeing like a human get mad
because of the humans same because it's
thought as personal that's a hundred
percent true I was in Long Beach and I
got really really mad at this [ __ ]
dirty ass car that cut me off and then
this [ __ ] Mexican dude to pop his
head out with a bunch of tattoos all
over him and I went they were
frightening as [ __ ] what's up blue home
I don't know all this [ __ ] but they're
seeing a bunch of [ __ ] wasn't with me at
the time I think Vince
they just screaming at me change my
attitude real quick and it was their
fault and I apologized I come in peace
yeah that's the first time you had
cameltoe huh yup just like my dick just
disappeared and then right there I just
learned about this hot-dogging is when
you look at me say it
hot-dogging is when you don't want to
bulge the show so you pull your Weiner
back instead into the bun who doesn't
want their bullets to show they forced
me to visualize it in my head you just
want me to visualize me go to the
[ __ ] barbell brigade [ __ ]
Instagram and look at some of our old
staff they did that in a [ __ ] video
all you got to do is put a nice ice pack
on it for ten minutes then it'll shrink
it right back 30 seconds oh yeah 30
seconds your balls feel so weird like
the wrinkles is so weird
swimming a cold [ __ ] poo that she
gets shriveled up
poopoo you're nuts go all the way up
your body like ovaries okay so a 65 year
old man clung to the hood SUV in
Massachusetts 65 what is he doing at
that he should be retired and I've seen
this video yeah so this man his name is
Richard and the driver of SUV is 37 year
old named Mark and they were both
involved in a minor sideswipe and so
they pulled over it to exchange
information Oh
the men got into an argument oh and
that's when Mark began to drive away but
then Richard was like no you're not
going anywhere and he jumped on the hood
I never argue with those fools where'd
you have you or do you think of the Hulk
either hold about what are you thinking
people try to argue this start trying to
like figure out what the blame is I know
it's pointless because the insurance is
gonna do their own investigation so they
all who why did you come out no it's
okay I can just get your license
registration please do I don't even if
they call it's my bad I should have
let's go it's okay cuz there's times
where I thought I was clearly in the
right and I was a hundred percent wrong
- mm-hmm hard car and I got hit by a
moving car are you sure you open the
door as the car was driving no and I had
a witness that's all of SUV or so I got
also before my catalytic converter got
stuff out of my Honda Element this lady
this look how it cracks you up - yeah
cuz it's just it would happen and then
this lady before I was gonna go train
with Nic this lady rear-ended the Honda
Element which is whatever is the hon
Elenin right and then she just kind of
like dented that back a little bit
this lady was so [ __ ] stupid because
I was telling her I was like okay it's
not that big of a [ __ ] deal just give
me whatever cash and I'll just go get it
fixed it's like a painting right it'll
be like 300 bucks yeah give me like 300
or 500 bucks and then we won't have to
report she goes no I don't want to do
that because what if you sue me later on
I'm like what it is not because
nothing's gonna be on paper like you
just give me the money and she goes no
so [ __ ] we had to file a whole police
review so we had to follow it so and
then I had to go insurance right
it was stupid because her deductible is
a thousand bucks oh my god not just to
pay a thousand dollars I said just give
me 300 bucks yeah
and so she calls me up you know AB
because we exchange numbers she goes
well my deductibles gonna be twice oh
can we just do cash it's like it's too
late you did the police report you dumb
[ __ ] so I was like what the [ __ ] are
you thinking is she goes well I don't
want it's too late
police report it's in there yeah cops
came to me were dumb though and Richards
even go up now exactly I think she's the
one that was in the wrong right exactly
she really ended me I was like what are
you thinking I was like you just wasted
a [ __ ] ton of money your premiums gonna
go up you have to pay $1,000 for your
deductible
she thinks that by giving you cash it's
gonna erase it
you're a Yelp reviewer and she's a
[ __ ] restaurant yeah what were you
thinking dude
anyway so back to mark and Richard here
so then once mark started driving off he
he went up to speeds of 70 miles an hour
while this man was holding on to the
five year old recording speeds of up to
70 miles an hour with a man dangling
from the hood the driver I thought you
were gonna roll me I thought he was
trying to run out the car dude East
Coasters don't [ __ ] around oh they got
some crazy road rage well I mean in a
summertime Californians aren't so nice
here they come I start shooting people
but I mean the type of [ __ ] talking that
they do I remember every time we would
go to shows out there there'll be some
sky yelling at the people that were like
driving or whatever oh my god wouldn't
Isaac and I went to New York the uber
driver that picked us up from the
airport eNOS to the hotel he was like
cursing up a storm and I'm like dude my
kid isn't here what the [ __ ] I mean
that's probably what they do I mean I
could think of two incidents one one was
um we were pulling out of a Plaza and it
there was a car behind us oh oh and you
look back that's all you see
hook and I'm like what's going on and he
goes oh it's just like he wants me to
hurry up I get scared to use my horn
sometimes because sometimes when you use
your horn you're using it to help
somebody out right cuz like for example
there was a dude that had his like gas
tank as his years ago but he had his gas
tank open and I just you know what I was
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] stupid yeah
but while he's getting these kids still
kept yelling at me cuz he's so enraged
it was like you I thought you were
talking [ __ ] yeah gasping gasping gas
tank and he's like what [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] jalopy [ __ ] mark and then our
driver was doing a [ __ ] three-point
turn in that street and in that car you
couldn't even wait to fall you started
cussing him out oh and he rolled down
his window and they started custody [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] you wanna [ __ ] go don't
wanna [ __ ] go and they just keep
driving yeah I'm like wow you guys I
think it's like you know at the end of
the club right there's always boys
fighting and trying to act hard and they
do the [ __ ] hold me back hold me back
I'm like is that what they do an East
Coast they do a lot of yelling in the
[ __ ] back and forth but no one really
gets out and fights I mean I think that
pisses me off the most is when I'm at a
red light
um and it's happened to me a couple
times I'm at a red light the light turns
green and immediately someone huh yeah
I'm like oh it just turned green [ __ ]
you
that's why you got to pull it David so
he's trying really slow dude remember
live petty walk that's how you do it
oh you tryna honk okay that's funny just
release the [ __ ] gas and let it roll
mm-hmm you know what though for LA being
a major city we have some really nice
drivers like they're very frank thrown
at me one why well deserved you look
thirsty no it was not one I was actually
honky so this girl she cut me off and I
was honking and I'm like what the [ __ ]
like we was during traffic times too and
I'll just like do that was like I had to
brake hello hard to not hit hurt yeah
and then this [ __ ] she comes around she
gets into the next Lane I end up passing
her and she throws me a drink what did
you do you catch it
hidden I know my window was up so I hit
my window and I just had soda all over
my driver window you with me when I
threw the orange juice at somebody no we
were going to I think we were about to
throw something at someone
okay that's somebody Austin but I do
have McDonald's orange juice thing
mumbles and but the driving culture is
ultimately pretty nice if you think
about it right have you ever actually
tried driving elsewhere in another major
city they don't let you win they don't
let you [ __ ] cut in or anything and
then what their idea is cutting off is
way [ __ ] like way more space than our
idea of cutting off yes cuz like there's
just no space and people have to weave
in and out all the time right I'm not
driving yeah I remember I was in like
Arizona and then I was on the freeway
cutting lanes this [ __ ] was like
three cars behind me going oh I can't
believe this book could be off I think
they're [ __ ] yelling at me oh my
the [ __ ] you know what I realize that we
have all the time that East Coasters
don't have high-speed pursuits because
they literally can't go anywhere Oh have
you thought about that because I get all
these notifications on my facebook
holders I don't really turn into the
East Coast news
oh yeah well I mean like all something's
cuz I was like my friend of ideas get
high-speed pursuit I don't think that's
gonna happen like in the city of New
York they literally cannot rush it all
the bridges are always [ __ ] going
like this all the time what are you
gonna pursue sometimes I'm like no show
you guys what we can like I don't know
we just get a mission all the time and
they have none it's hard for me to get
mad because I always feel like
everyone's an idiot so I'm like hey
weren't you the guy was starting change
at cars before when I was younger
come on now I was 19 that's different
but now it's hard for me to get max on
my okay I'm dumb you're dumb we're all
gonna make human error human error is
gonna happen someone's no one's gonna be
on their best day so I like even when
people cut me off or the people that
like you can tell that like I'm like
really far away something okay if you
want to turn into my lane go now go now
go now I'm okay you're not gonna do is I
keep going awesome they come out right
in front of you and have to slam on my
brakes I'm still like oh he's just dumb
it's so hard driving in a Chinese
neighborhood like this man like it's
hard not being angry dude well it's hard
because I'm also part of the problem
yeah like I'm a terrible driver so like
I mean I still get road rage you know
and all the like I think the bad things
I did when I was younger cuz I thought I
was a good driver but it turns out like
if I calculate how many times I [ __ ]
up it's definitely more than things that
happened to me I only get road rage if I
do something nice and they're pissed oh
yeah I've slowed down and I let someone
in and for some reason they came up to
me flick me off on the side that's when
I got pissed people I thought you were
break checking them or something no no
they were there in front of me oh I
slowed down to let them come in front of
me because I'm always will need to get
in what the [ __ ] yeah I'm like super
brave now because of a dashcam so I'm
just like hit me please hit me
please hit me I want some money you know
like now I'm just brave oh dude I would
love when I had that camera I wanted
somebody to sideswiped me so hard dude
and I wanted to come out with my
forearms you start dragging my life
behind me Herbert's dog [ __ ] yeah cuz
you know what I was so poor when I came
down please somebody just looking like a
war took in my mind you know he ain't
into arguments in the shower in my mind
what I want to happen is I want them to
hit me and then have the cops come and
they go all crazy like oh no she don't
hurt me and I'm just sit there like oh I
have a camera nice guy like maybe last
year or two years ago I was driving and
then I think I wasn't paying attention
like I always do on the brake I was
still moving forward and so I hit the
guy in the back and I immediately look
at his rearview mirror and I see him
look at me and I go like do you want to
like pull over and he's like I'm like oh
[ __ ] that was tight who's just like a
little bump but it was cool that we were
able to communicate and communicate to
me I his really carries around weekend
last time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]